Monique starts off this hour in
Minneapolis hey Monique how are you well
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I have a question for you I'm
wondering if I should use some of the
money that I have in stock or retirement
to kick-start my debt payoff I have a I
do have three soon-to-be four children
so and I would say my my total debt is a
pretty big number but wanting to
kick-start things and making sure I get
on the right path I can start saving etc
get to the other steps not counting your
house how much do you have
so I have about 150 K in debt okay and
what's your household income by myself
I'm at one point where you buy yourself
oh I'm married but my husband filed for
bankruptcy individually so it's I kind
of keep his stuff separate because all
of his stuff has rolled into his
bankruptcy and so he's just kind of
separated things so that it would impact
the household financial so yes okay
and so how much debt does he have in the
chapter 13 bankruptcy he has a hundred
roughly 120 mm-hmm okay what does he
make it you 165 okay and what do you
make a year
one boy okay all right so one way of
looking at this is that you have a
$300,000 income I don't understand why
you're in bankruptcy well he's in
bankruptcy because at the time you're
married we are in bankruptcy right okay
so at the time that he filed he
was not working she was just kind of
like at a I made a hundred and forty
thousand dollars a year yes and I still
have my 140 K in debt wanted we have 150
yeah okay so what you tell me all right
150 yeah how much money do you have
either one of you have in accounts stock
accounts or whatever that are not inside
of a retirement account 8k that are not
inside of a retirement account $8,000
yes okay all right okay
and I mean I have money saved in my like
savings account so probably like another
10 K for you want to call it emergencies
or whatever but all right so here's the
way
number one I will tell you that in
studying ten thousand-plus millionaires
and in doing this for 30 years I find
virtually zero married couples get ahead
financially and become wealthy
regardless of their incomes if they
don't work together as one unit you are
not doing that you're violating that
you've got to work together as one unit
to solve these things the bad news is
you have two hundred and seventy
thousand dollars in debt the good news
is you make three hundred and five
thousand dollars and that's the way I
would look at it if I were you based on
30 years of me doing this if you want to
win if you want to be divorced then go
be divorced but you can't you can't have
you can't you're not to paint or get off
the ladder so you got to decide what you
is and you're not two individual units
that happen to be in the same household
he's not your roommate he's your husband
and so you guys working together for
better for worse and richer for poorer
unto thee all my worldly goods I pledge
is the old-fashioned marriage vows and
that's how building wealth works for a
married couple the most often one
percent chance of making it if you don't
do that
that's your probabilities based on 30
years of me doing this I just don't
find it happening where you drag along a
wounded partner instead of standing up
dusting off and we hold hands and we
hold each other and we're getting a
death grip of a bear hug and we work
through this crap together so I would
lay out a strategy with your fabulous
income to clean up your debt if you
lived on 50 thousand a year
household income is your as your living
expenses which would be the normal
household income in America is 54
thousand by the way so if I put you on a
normal Americans household income
not counting taxes that would free up
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year to attack two hundred and seventy
thousand dollars in debt
- taxes that means you're a hundred
percent debt-free with the bankruptcy
dismissed in two years I just don't know
if that's possible because of the cost
of child care because we have three
things before kids you just tell your
child care is going to keep you from
putting two hundred fifty thousand
dollars you really believe job he really
believed childcare is 100 thousand
dollars a year that's the way you just
stated that not not okay they're okay
it's a minor issue it's mathematically a
non-starter
so it could you know are my numbers
exactly right is it gonna take you
exactly 24 months not might take you 18
it might take you 27 but it's absurd for
you all to stay in debt and in
bankruptcy with the kind of incomes that
you all have if you were to join arms
and actually learn to work together this
is not obviously the news you wanted
when you called but that's okay I'm here
to Le'Veon not to make you mine not that
I'm not taking a poll I'm here to help
you so this is what this is what works
kiddo and that's what I would tell you
to do
you're bright people dumb people don't
make $300,000 a year
so you're bright but you're violating
common-sense ethic and the data points
that you're violating are not going to
get you there the the process that
you're using so please two of you sit
down together and say how can we get out
of this mess given that we have this
a large shovel and we have this
medium-sized hole you know if you call
me if you're making twenty seven
thousand dollars a year and you had this
debt I would be going huh ones you're
gonna do but the good news is you have
this fabulous income if you will just
say no to you and really detail out a
scorched-earth budget you can clear this
debt in an amazingly short period of
time the math right there in front of
you yeah you got some childcare expense
that's there and you know you're
obviously carrying a child which is
wonderful another blessing you've got
and that does affect your
decision-making as well and so that's
what you got to look at but but you can
do this I know you can do this I know
you can do this more than you know you
can do this because I've seen people
just like you do it